When we start talking about robots and the
need for sensors, the question that many people
ask is: ‘Why don’t we just use GPS, surely
that’s enough?’. GPS is everywhere—it’s
in our phones, it’s in our cars … it tells
us where we are. So let’s talk a little
bit about GPS.
Imagine we have a robot on the ground and
it’s got a GPS receiver in its head. In
the sky are a number of satellites in low
earth orbit, and they are all sending radio
waves which the GPS receiver in the robot’s
head can pick up.
Using the time that it takes the radio wave
to travel from each satellite to the robot
we can work out the distance from each satellite to the robot.
If we know enough of these distances—we know where the satellites are in space—
then we can work out where the robot is.
That’s the fundamental principle of GPS.
Now these radio waves are at a very high frequency;
they are around about 1.5 gigahertz, and that’s
significant and we’ll talk about why that’s
significant shortly.
Imagine now we’re looking upwards from the
robot. We’re looking up to the sky, and
there are a number of satellites that we can
see. We only need four satellites in fact,
to work out where we are on the planet. That’s
the minimum requirement in order to get what’s
called a ‘fix’.
Now imagine that our robot is in an urban
environment. Imagine we’re on a street in
Manhattan or something like that. So what
happens now is that some part of the sky is
obscured. We can’t see all of the satellites.
Now we can only see two satellites and that’s
not enough to obtain a fix. This is a very
common phenomenon, that’s why we have problems
with GPS in urban environments. But it occurs
in other environments as well. It can occur
perhaps in a very, very deep mining pit where
the walls of the pit obscure a significant
fraction of the sky.
Now imagine that we have our robot and it’s
at some big industrial complex. There are
large walls and chimneys and structures made
out of metal. Now what happens in this case
is that the signals from the satellite may
not travel in a direct line to the robot.
They may bounce off some of these metallic
structures before they hit the robot. The
problem with this is that the signals have
travelled a longer distance than the actual
distance between the robot and the satellite.
The path length has increased through what’s
called ‘multi-pathed reflection’. So the
GPS receiver within the robot doesn’t know
this, so it will come up with an erroneous
estimate of where the robot is located.
This is, again, quite a common problem with
GPS next to a big structure that reflects
radio waves. The GPS estimated robot position
can be significantly in error.
Now let’s consider another scenario. Consider
that our robot is underground, perhaps doing
some mining work, a really important domain
for robots. Now the problem that we have here
is that the radio waves from the satellite
cannot penetrate the earth.
Another application where we might want to
use robots is underwater. And again we have
the same problem as we have in the underground
case. The radio waves at 1.5 gigahertz cannot
penetrate very far into water. They perhaps
penetrate a few millimetres. So a robot that’s
at any depth can make absolutely no use of
GPS information.
Now let’s consider a situation we’re outdoors
but there are trees above the robot. The problem
we have here is actually very similar to the
last one. There is a lot of water in the leaves
of the trees, and particularly after it has
been raining then there’s a lot of the water
on the surface of the leaves. And this water
absorbs the 1.5 gigahertz radio waves from
the satellite, and they won’t penetrate.
So with heavy tree canopy GPS radio waves
are absorbed, and we’re not going to get
enough information for the robot to obtain
a fix.
But there’s another and perhaps deeper reason
why GPS is not the solution to all robotic
problems. Consider this kind of typical case
where I’ve got a robot and it wants to pick
up an object.
So this robot wants to pick up that banana.
Now I can add a GPS receiver to the robot,
so the robot now knows where it is in the
world. But it doesn’t really help, because
it doesn’t really know where the banana
is. So I can add a GPS receiver to the banana,
and now the banana knows where it is; the
robot knows where it is. But it still hasn’t
helped with this problem of this robot knowing
where the banana is so that it can move and
grasp it. So in order to get information about
the banana’s position to the robot I could
add a radio transmitter to this GPS receiver
on the banana, and I could add a receiver
to the robot. So now the robot knows where
the banana is, it has the coordinates of the
banana; it knows where it is, and having those
two pieces of information, the robot can then
plan a path in order to get from here to there.
Now while this might work, the fundamental
problem is that every object that the robot
would want to pick up, work with and manipulate
needs to be fitted with this kind of instrumentation,
and clearly this is not the way we solve this
problem. If I want to pick up the banana I
simply reach out, I use my eyes to work out
where it is and guide my hand in order to
pick it up.